a legendary Warrior Queen 10 000 ships
and one heck of a shattered glass
ceiling but what does any of this have
to do with House of the Dragon in the
black queen the first season finale of
HBO's massively successful Game of
Thrones prequel House of the Dragon the
Targaryen civil war known as the dance
of the Dragons begins in Earnest in the
green Corner you've got Alison's
Hightower the Widow of King viserys
Targaryen and mother to aegon Targaryen
The Young King she just installed on the
Iron Throne as for the blacks says
rhaenyra Targaryen daughter to viserys
and his intended Heir who has spent her
whole life preparing to sit on the
throne once childhood friends and
confidants these two women have spent
their adult years completely at odds
especially as their children are fought
amongst each other during the events of
the black queen Alison's father and
handled the king Otto Hightower tries to
bargain with rhaenyra on his daughter's
behalf and in doing so he brings her a
small token of the former friendship
between the two women and also
approaches Rainier error and her
formidable husband Damon on the bridge
that leads to Dragonstone he tries to
make a bargain with them if they bend
the knee to aegon and accept him as
their King he'll let rhaenyra and her
sons keep Dragonstone he also suggested
her sons will serve as Squires and
cupbearers to Alison's children Damon
definitely doesn't means words about his
feelings on the matter understandably
rhaenyra feels the same way going so far
as to throw Otto's pin signifying his
status as hand into the sea this
betrayal of rhaenyra's Father's wishes
clearly infuriates both her and Damon
but at the last minute
Otto produces a gift from Alison
benfarainira has seems to soften her
just a little
Otto gives rhaenyra an envelope
containing a torn page from a book that
she and Alison read together when they
were young the page focuses on nymeria a
fierce Warrior who brought a fleet of 10
000 ships across the narrow sea when she
faced attacks from enemies in valyria
when the two girls read it in the Show's
first episode they're still close
friends and clearly the page brings back
memories for a mirror
[Applause]
seems to be missing a huge part of the
story however in that nymeria ended up
taking over the region of Dawn and
rolling as Queen after her husband
Morris Martell died in battle My Maria
became a warrior in her own right and
vanquished enough of her opponents to
fully rule Dawn and end the tradition of
male primogeniture as both rhaenis and
rhaenyra have directly told Alison
drawing House of the Dragon the widowed
Queen has proven herself to be perfectly
happy to follow the lead of the men in
her life time and time again rarely
striking out on her own terms
free but make a window in the wall of
your prison beyond that nymeria would
certainly have harsh words for a woman
who is actively supplanting another
woman's legitimate claim to the throne
by insisting that only a man can rule
clearly rhaenyra internalized a lot more
about nymeria than Alison did then again
after the end of the episode it's clear
that Alison's gesture won't even matter
going forward